a collective sigh of relief today as a
strike by cp rail workers comes to an
end this is a very big deal for farmers
but also consumers right across the
country and marianne dumaine joins us
live with the latest details good
afternoon to you marianne so if you
could break down how this all went and
the timeline of it all too
good afternoon candace well i can tell
you they're not going to need these
picket signs behind me here like they
did over the past two days instead three
thousand unionized workers from
engineers conductors and even rail yard
staff are back on the job this hour and
that's including here in the city's east
end where we are right now and that's
after cp rail and the union agreed on
final and binding arbitration early this
morning we know that trains did come to
a halt on sunday as both sides tried to
reach an agreement but this morning they
started slowly moving again teamster's
canada rail conference says binding
arbitration wasn't the preferred method
but it said it managed to negotiate
terms that are in the best interest of
its members members who stopped work and
were out with signs for the past two
days the union says wages and pensions
do remain key stumbling blocks now the
agreement means cp can resume essential
services for the north american supply
chain
there were concerns that if the work
stoppage went any longer it would
severely impact canada's supply chain
and even grocery store shelves here's
more from one expert on what we avoided
if this
labor dispute would have dragged on uh
it would have been quite problematic for
farmers uh in the us uh in asia around
the world to get fertilizers to increase
productivity because this year it's it's
it's going to be quite critical given
what's going on in ukraine there is
going to be a deficit of commodities
including wheat corn barley so we need
all the help we can get
and since we've been here this morning
there have already been some trains that
left the area and you can see this hour
there are some crews there continuing
some work on the tracks as for the union
it says it will not be speaking to the
media until this whole arbitration
process is complete i'll send it back to
you candace okay thanks so much that is
marianne demaine reporting